done already let's go to the solution in
the menu layout file for the main
activity called main dot XML we add
another menu item there will always be
in the overflow menu we also define the
string in the strings dot XML file
the menu will be inflated in the main
activity class so we can handle the map
menu item being inflated by calling
helper method called open preferred
location and map the helper method reads
the users preferred location from shared
preferences then we create a view intent
indicating its location in the data URI
the format of the data URI was from the
documentation page on common intense
where you can append a postal code as a
query parameter finally we start an
activity with this intent note that we
only start the activity if the activity
resolves successfully